-The president called
the charges against him
"impeachment lite,"
as one of his main conspiracy
theories about the FBI
was officially debunked.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yesterday, the House unveiled
articles of impeachment
against a president for only
the fourth time in history.
Now, if you were worried about
getting fired
and you were trying to prove
that you were,
in fact, qualified for your job,
you might decide
to try to behave
like a normal, sane person.
Instead, Trump decided to go
to Pennsylvania last night
for one of his deranged rallies
and do his usual routine
of slurring like a lunatic
while throwing in
some of his trademark sexism.
-The president of Ukraine
repeatedly declared
that there was no pressure,
but he didn't want to say that.
We said, "Say it. Say it,
you crooked bastard. Say it."
You'd have windmills
all over the place
if you had crooked Hillary.
They'd be knocking out
those birds left and right.
Those windmills,
"Wah, wah, wah."
Beto. Beto.
[ Rally audience booing ]
Remember?
So, he wanted to get rid
of religion, the bible.
Crazy Elizabeth Warren --
I give her credit.
I thought she was left for.
I mean, there were, like,
just little embers,
and then she rose.
She rose and she became strong.
But then she opened that fresh
mouth of hers, and it stopped.
-"She opened her fresh mouth"?
You sound like the headmaster
of a private school
called St. Misogynist Academy.
Elizabeth Warren
has detailed plans
for things people
actually care about
like corruption and equality
and climate change.
Your energy plan is that
windmills sound like "wah, wah.
Wah."
Trump's obviously rattled by the
fact that he's about to become
the third president ever
in history to be impeached.
No matter what happens next,
Trump's name will be
emblazoned in history
as one of only three presidents
to be impeached,
and that will follow him
forever.
They're gonna have to
put an asterisk
next to Trump's name
on his building
with a footnote below it
that says "impeached."
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...House Democrats
decided to exercise restraint
and file only two articles
of impeachment against Trump
despite the fact that they
could've filed many more.
I mean, this guy obstructed
justice, solicited a bribe,
and was literally identified
as Individual One
in a court filing
involving an illegal scheme
to pay hush money
to cover up an affair,
and we know Individual One
was Trump
because the document also said,
"Individual One began
an ultimately successful
campaign
for president
of the United States."
That was in a court filing.
I mean, think about
how crazy that is.
That's never happened before.
It's not like Abraham Lincoln
was ever named in an indictment
as Honest Man in Very Large Hat
Number One.
And yet Trump yesterday
actually taunted Democrats
for not filing
even more charges against him
by mocking how limited the
articles of impeachment were.
-You saw their so called
articles of impeachment today.
People are saying, "They're not
even a crime. What happened?
All of these horrible things.
Remember?
Bribery, and this and that.
Where are they?"
They send these two things.
They're not even a crime.
This is the lightest,
weakest impeachment.
You know, our country's had
actually many impeachments.
You call judges and lots
of other -- many impeachments.
But it was on today.
Everybody says,
"This is impeachment lite."
This is the lightest impeachment
in the history of our country
by far.
-You're either impeached
or your not.
There's no light version.
Trump's like a drunk guy at
a bar on his sixth beer going,
"It's impeachment lite.
Now give me my keys!"
Trump needs --
he desperately needs
these group therapy sessions
with his fawning admirers
so he could lie to himself
and soothe his ego.
For example, he also made this
ludicrous statement about
how the world has reacted
to his presidency.
-This country is so respected,
and we were not respected
four years ago.
We were laughed at.
-Dude,
it was literally last week
that a bunch of world leaders
were caught laughing at you
in a group chat
during the NATO summit,
including your buddy
Boris Johnson.
And if you're getting laughed at
by this guy,
you know you are an idiot.
Boris Johnson would be
the world's Donald Trump
if there wasn't already
an actual Donald Trump.
Boris Johnson must be
so happy Donald Trump exists.
It's like in middle school
when the chess nerd finds out
the school has a LARPing nerd.
He's like, "I'm off the hook!"
In fact, today in the UK,
Johnson dodged questions
from reporters
during a campaign stop
at a dairy farm
by literally
hiding in a freezer.
-Mr. Johnson,
we only have five minutes.
Could you talk to us?
-I'll be with you in a second.
I'll be with you in a second.
-I have an ear piece here
in my hand ready to go.
Right. He's been taken inside
into the freezer.
-He hid in the freezer.
Although, it's hard to tell
with him,
because he always looks like
he was just locked in a freezer.
I mean, if you put Trump's hair
on Jack from the "Shining,"
you'd get Boris Johnson.
That is...how that looks.
So, as usual, Trump's rally was
totally detached from reality.
In fact, Trump went to
such lengths to soothe his ego
in the face of
a historic political reckoning
that at one point, he literally
gave himself credit
for saving people's marriages
with an obviously
made-up story
about how happy people are
about their 401(k)s.
-I have so many people that come
up to me, "Thank you, sir.
My wife is so in love with me
because I went up 79%
in the 401(k).
She thinks I'm a genius.
She always thought
I was a total stiff --
a dumb, stupid dope.
Now she thinks
I'm a financial genius, sir."
-First of all, if your spouse
thought you were a dumb,
stupid dope
until your 401(k) went up,
your marriage
still has problems.
I do wonder
where Trump got the idea
that wives
only love their husbands
if they have a lot of money.
I guess we'll never know.
Now, you might recall that
since virtually the start
of his presidency
Trump has harbored
a deranged conspiracy theory
that there was a secret cell of
treasonous deep-state saboteurs
within the government
trying to take him down,
you know, like an insane person.
He's one step away from claiming
his aids are
actually secret lizard people,
when we know for a fact
they're obvious lizard people.
Why else would Stephen Miller's
eyes blink sideways?
Trump has continued to repeat
this conspiracy theory
even though
it's already been debunked,
including by an Inspector
General's report on Monday
and by the Inspector General
himself at a hearing today.
Now, you might remember that
this whole insane
conspiracy theory started
when Trump tweeted this
out of nowhere
a few months
into his presidency.
"Terrible.
Just found out that Obama
had my wires tapped
in Trump Tower
just before the victory,"
and then "How low has President
Obama gone to tap my phones
during the very sacred
election process?
This is Nixon Watergate --
bad or sick guy."
That was March of 2017.
Remember when we thought
that was the craziest thing
a president ever said?
We were so young.
Also, I love Trump's
parentheticals --
bad or sick guy.
It's like
a choose-your-own adventure book
for insane people.
"If you think Obama was good,
turn to page 10.
If you think he was bad,
turn to page 27,
and if you think he's sick,
I'd like to offer you
Secretary of Agriculture."
Trump's about to face
a historic political reckoning
for a simple reason --
he abused his power,
he tried to cover it up,
and he got caught.
And now his only move is to spin
dark fantasies of subterfuge
and paranoia to scare his base
and keep them in line.
But sometimes
he even undercuts himself.
At the rally yesterday,
for example,
he told his fawning admirers
that Democrats were trying
to overthrow the government
simply by following
the impeachment procedures
laid out in the Constitution.
But in the next breath,
he told them
it wasn't that big of a deal.
-The radical left Democrats
and the failed
Washington establishment
are trying to erase your votes,
nullify the election,
and overthrow our Democracy.
Not gonna happen.
Don't worry about it.
I wouldn't lose too much sleep
over it.
-If we're not
supposed to worry about it,
why are you telling us?
He's like a dad at a campfire
who realizes his spooky stories
are scaring the kids,
so he pulls back.
"They say
these woods are haunted
by a killer in a hockey mask
who waits for little children
to go to bed
so he can chop up their bodies,
but now that I think about it,
he was arrested and he's in
prison, so you know, it's fine.
Just forget
Daddy said that part.
Don't tell Mommy
I said that part."
Turns out, of course, that the
conspiracy theory was insane
and on Monday became official
when the Justice Department
Inspector General
released his findings.
It said that while there were
serious errors
with parts of
the Russia investigation,
it was both valid and justified.
The only thing Republicans have
been able to hang their hat on
is the fact that two FBI agents
sent text messages to each other
disparaging Trump,
even though there were also
FBI employees who sent pro-Trump
and anti-Hillary messages,
and yet at the hearing today,
GOP Senator Lindsey Graham
selectively read the anti-Trump
messages out loud
for everyone to hear.
-February 12, 2016.
"Oh, he's" -- Trump --
"abysmal."
March 3, 2016.
Page, "God,
Trump is a loathsome human."
Strzok, "Oh, my God.
He's an idiot."
March 16, 2016.
"I cannot believe Donald Trump
is likely to be actual serious
candidate for President."
July 16th. We're getting closer
to when this thing opens.
"And, wow, Donald Trump
is an enormous douche."
Again, a lot of people
agree with them.
-Those messages
don't prove anything.
You can't go
anywhere in the world
without hearing
opinions about Trump.
I'm pretty sure there are people
stranded on deserted islands
in the Bermuda Triangle putting
rocks together that say
"Trump is a douche."
I mean, think about weak
the president's position is.
He's been reduced to arguing
that being impeached
isn't that bad
because it's impeachment lite,
and now
his key conspiracy
theory
claiming
the whole thing was a hoax
has been officially debunked
by the Justice Department
Inspector General.
At this point, the only way
things could get worse for Trump
is if the House passed a third
article of impeachment
calling Trump...
-"An enormous douche."
-This has been "A Closer Look."